Film Courage: Let’s talk about the good,
bad and ugly of screenwriting meetings.
So how does a writer personally contribute
to the success or failure of pitching meeting?
Or maybe it’s not really within their control,
but they feel they’ve contributed to it.
Larry Wilson: Well you do contribute to it
and it’s really grossly unfair to having
been on the other side of the desk, having
been a studio executive.
Everyone has pitch nightmare stories and they
are true.
But it’s really unfair to development people
and executives to assume that everyone in
those meetings is there to basically make
your life miserable and say no to you.
It’s not true.
And how you contribute to it as a writer?
You come in with an idea that you’ve actually
thought through and that you have some passion
for.
And that also, you need to be willing to listen.
It’s a conversation and the control you
have of the conversation is you’re the one
coming in with the idea, you’re the one
coming in saying “Hey I think this would
be a great movie.
This would be a great television show.”
Whatever…and you should have thought it
through and you should have prepared well-enough
to when they say “Well why do you think
it’s such a great idea?” to be able to
answer the questions.
And you should know enough about your story
that you can do it justice in the room.
But then having sat as an executive, I’ve
also been in those meetings where you say
to someone “Yeah, I get it but…”
And they immediately “What but?
There is no but!
This is the story.
You have nothing to say to me!”
And a defensiveness goes up and that’s a
huge mistake.
Don’t go to the meeting.
Just write the stupid script.
It’s a conversation and it’s a dialogue.
And don’t assume that you know more than
the person in the room who you are speaking
to.
Have it as a conversation and be strong and
know when you need to dig in your heels.
And know that if people are changing your
story in the room so much that you don’t
even recognize it anymore (which could happen),
that you need to say no and say thank you
for the meeting and leave.
But engage in the conversation.
Having a little bit of effing humility, for
gosh sakes, you know?
You’ve been invited into the room to tell
someone a story.
Don’t assume that they don’t have a thought
in their head.
And there are so many stories (and again),
a lot of them are true.
And I could tell you nightmare stories about
pitches.
We could stay here all night and I could tell
you those stories.
But I could also tell you great stories with
great development people who have given me
enough rope to hang myself, then said “Well
what if this happened or that happened?”
And they’ve given me a better idea and a
better take.
It’s a dialogue and a conversation and it’s
part of the business and I hate to call it
a game but I will for a moment, it’s part
of the game.
But if you just can’t stand the idea of
going in and telling a story and someone’s
going to try and change it or have an idea,
write the script.
Don’t be a pitch monkey, be a screenwriter.
Film Courage: So then how does a screenwriter
keep their side of the street clean?
Whatever happens on the other side of that
desk, whether the person’s kind with their
suggestions or not, how do they keep their
own integrity…and remain poised and all
of that?
Larry Wilson: By having integrity.
And knowing that you are going in with something
that you believe in and that you’re excited
about.
And so if they completely don’t get it or
say stuff that you think has nothing to do
with what you just pitched with them, you
know within yourself that the story you went
in to tell is the story you want to tell and
you really believe it can be a movie and you
can be really excited about it.
Integrity is an inside job.
And if you’re looking to have your integrity
brought to you by Hollywood, oh my gosh!
Film Courage: No?
Larry Wilson: No!
It’s an inside job and if I go in to pitch
a story, I don’t do it unless I believe
in it.
And I may be wrong.
I may be wildly wrong.
But I won’t leave going “You know what,
I thought I’d put that one over on them,
but they didn’t get it but oh well.”
I mean I’ll go “I told the best story
I could.”
And then you let it go.
You just let it go.
It’s a good meeting.
It’s a bad meeting but you did your best.
And that’s an inside job.
And it’s a learned experience, too.
And you will come out of meetings wondering
who you are and what you’re going to be
when you grow up.
I still have meetings like that but most of
the time I come away feeling good.
Film Courage: Yeah…that was my next question.
Because it sounds like you just have to go
through it, have a few [meetings] where basically
you are in the fetal position when you go
home.
And then it’s less so, you’re just on
the couch and then the next time you just
take a walk around the block.
Larry Wilson: Yeah…and I don’t end up
in the fetal position much anymore because
I believe in what I do.
It doesn’t mean anyone else has to believe
in it, but I believe in it.
Film Courage: But it sounds like it’s a
learned thing and there is no magic answer?
Larry Wilson: No.
No, there is no magic answer and it’s one
of those things that I’ve seen people get
crushed in these meetings, crushed where they
can’t come back again and that’s again
that thing about having an over-developed
sense of perfection, perfectionism to say
it more simply that will be your worst enemy.
You had a bad meeting.
There was this time when everything was supposed
to be based on Joseph Campbell, remember those
days?
When everything you had to go in and if you
were going to pitch something and Joseph Campbell
was going to end up in the sentence.
And I was going in with a producer who said
“Now remember to get the Joseph Campbell
moments in there!”
And I was pitching, I was about three minutes
into it and the guy across the desk said “Oh
jeez.
Can we get over the Joseph Campbell stuff.
Can you just tell me the story?”
And the meeting died a horrible death.
And I should never have done it.
I should have just said “Here’s the story.
If you see Joseph Campbell in it, good for
you.”
But those are those things…don’t trick
yourself, just go ahead and tell the best
story that you can.